I've got my June snowman bun back baby I
know selfie sounds like that's what I
want my John Snow 2040 reboot to be I'm
Greg I'm John we are gonna do an
unboxing video our friends over at think
Jam have sent us over a package it's
just this little thing he sarcastically
says segwaying into a giant freakin box
right here I don't want it yes you do I
do I want it
oh I'm keeping it it's all mine now
course it's all mine it's all for you
Damien what at all I just want to open
this because it's so big and I just like
using the knife I just want to make a
slasher movie about you opening other
people's packets
hey I'm a badass alright alright alright
alright John will not clean that up were
smart about that bit what the cat's mess
you one more part about that big anyway
whoa laterally moly we don't even need
to get a picture in certain of this
weekend devily oh yeah you jus jazz our
non impeach president would say yeah
let's see what's in this bad boy
are you ready I am NOT ready but ya
already heard whoa
okay alright oh damn things first the
complete series of Game of Thrones
Thrones cube we can watch how it
undoubtably progressively gets better
we've heard Jon I talk about the final
season of Game of Thrones and even
though we weren't huge fans of it there
was still plenty just talking about it
someone at a party yesterday happy
birthday Tara Erikson and I was like you
know I actually really liked the first
half of the last season I still think
it's one of the best shows of all time
even though I am one of the people heck
rise to the final season
I'm happy that I can pop this in any
time and just cancel my HBO now
subscription oh yeah
forget Watchmen forget everything else
now that I have all nothing I have all
the blu-rays the Game of Thrones baby oh
this is so cool yeah plus you could like
beat someone to death with that if you
needed to nominate it for a
record-breaking 161 Emmy Awards wow
that's a lot
oh whoa whoa there's more stuff here
what this a love pop card on the love
pop card it looks like a pop-up book
version of a greeting card oh really
yeah so like there's got to be a dragon
that pops up dragons dun dun dun dun dun
dun dude there's a little Daenerys on
there yeah flowing blonde locks she's
like ah screw King's Landing yeah
there's a blahblah bubble that says that
you can't see what else is in there gee
this oh that's my Ally that's a notebook
great a journal Game of Thrones the
night king oh wow looky there alright
since I'm so generous you could have the
journal Joe thanks blank paper we dare
you are so fortunate I'd marry Chris to
write and draw thanks great getting this
for me for Christmas John very generous
what can I say I took a page out of
Daenerys as generosity and decided to
give it to you
I mean it's just because that's okay I'm
gonna stroke the cover because it's in
3d it looks like there's more stuff but
there's a few more there's more in the
in the crypts I was just gonna say that
you go I was just gonna say that yep
Merry Christmas
that's my gift to you is what I've never
had a Christmas sweater well then you
should have this one and apparently the
people I think Jam where I think I'm an
extra large well it's okay though cuz
it's like a sweater you know the point
is to be all cozy and
you know it's extra wool for you yeah oh
my god and I just went to a party where
they said we're Christmas when I'm like
I've never had one Christmas Merry
Christmas ugly sweater
what is this a a drink nog and I know
things I drink
nog this stalking oh my god oh my god or
the single-minded Christmas celebrated I
hope Santa doesn't just assume that this
is for the cast although maybe those
will be better presents oh wow all the
house sigil ZAR on it Oh John we gotta
come they all pose this and this would
be easy just sorry we could have just
gone with E the actual first other but
yeah why not go I yeah well this is
great thank you guys so much Game of
Thrones their complete series is now out
on all kinds of formats but physical is
the best one I don't know where you
could get any of these things but at
least the complete series box set will
probably be available at a store near
you yes
oh and the DVD includes a whole bunch of
stuff the documentary the last watch
when winter falls a 30-minute featurette
with Benioff and Weiss oh yeah machines
deleted and extended scenes wow there's
a whole bunch of things you got on here
reunion special there's a Ryu already a
reunion special every gamer like Conan
awesome
with what hosted by cohn awesome yes I
love Conan dude we got to bust into that
and react to the code man well thank you
guys again go get yourself a game of
Thrones box set today and Happy Holidays
no only Christmas all right